I know that proof has been announced of
a unsolved so far conjecture called the
ABC conjecture
if this proof is right then it's going
to be news on the scale of Fermat's Last
Theorem was in the 90s which was this
big unsolved problem it was this huge
event so it's really exciting and we
don't know if this proof is right yet so
a Japanese mathematician called Matta
zuki has released these papers and all
together is 500 pages long he's been
working on this for a very long time
he's come up with his own theory of
maths a whole new body of maths and he's
called it inter universal geometry I
know nothing about that very few people
do even the experts don't know much
about this at the moment so it's going
to take a very long time to make sure if
the proof is right because they're gonna
have to learn this whole new theory of
mathematics
so the ABC conjecture involves the most
simple formula you can think of it's
this a plus B equals C doesn't get much
easier than that and that's where it
gets its name from the rules are these
are whole numbers and they don't share
any factors so that means if I can
divide a by two then I'm not allowed to
divide B by two or if I could divide a
by 3 then B is not allowed to be
divisible by 3 then I have to share any
factors like that all right let's try an
example that works 1,024 plus 81 he
calls 1105 right now let's just check
they don't share any factors in fact I
picked these on purpose this one is 2 to
the power 10 and this one is 3 to the
power 4 so they don't share any factors
there oh and this one I'll do the same
is 5 times 13 times 17 now this is what
I want you to notice on the left hand
side you've got lots of prime numbers
we've got all 10 of them over here and
another 4 loads of them over here on the
right hand side you only have three and
this is what you tend to see most of the
time this is what's normal you get if
you get lots of Prime's on the left you
only get a few on the right hand side so
this is what the conjecture is about I
want to show you one where it doesn't
work 3 plus 125 that's equal to 128
let's just check they don't share any
factors then last 3 this is 5 or cubed
and this 128 is 2 to the power 7 now
this one is not like the first one I
showed you we've only got a few Prime's
on the left but we've got loads more on
the right we've got more on the right
than you do on the left that's unusual
that's weird so rather than not working
like I said earlier it's the unusual
example these don't happen so often so
the
Nakul way to see this is this times
those Prime's together start making it
up so 2 times 3 times 5 times 13 times
17 and that equals to thirteen thousand
two hundred and sixty there's a big
number and it's bigger than the right
hand side which was this that's what you
that's what normally happens okay so if
you do this you get a bigger number I'll
show you this one that I said wasn't
unusual it would do the same thing three
times five times 2 that's equal to 30
and that's smaller than 128 so that's
the difference so this is unusual this
is much smaller than the right hand side
this number which when you multiply the
primes together it's called the radical
of ABC it's called the radical because
it is well wicked the ABC conjecture is
the radical which I told you how to work
that out that's this the radical of ABC
it's bigger than the right hand side
guys they never see right that's what
you get normally in fact the conjecture
it's more than that
it talks about the powers of that two
but there are exceptions and these are
the exceptions when K equals one that's
the power is one there are infinitely
many exceptions just like the one I've
just shown you they're infinitely many
even though I said these were the rare
ones the unusual ones there are
infinitely many of them but if you take
a power bigger than one even if it's
only a little bit bigger even if it's
like a power of one point zero zero zero
zero one tiny tiny little bit bigger if
it's a bigger than one then you get
finite finitely many exceptions and this
is a little bit surprising because yes
if it's just a little bit bigger than 1
you get finitely many exceptions you
could count them off you could write
them down
you could say here are all the
exceptions for this power and that's
unusual
that's unexpected now this is the
conjecture it's very abstract it's very
pure this was made in the 80s this
conjecture but if this can be proven
what what it's going to do is it's going
to prove a whole bunch of other stuff at
a stroke and that's why it's big news
originally they thought that Fermat's
theorem which I talked about being
solved in the 90s they thought that this
was the way to solve it because there is
a way that if you can solve this you can
solve a version of Fermat's theorem it
didn't turn out that way because firma
sauce there and was solved first I heard
of it I think before it went around the
nerdy blogs and I thought well we could
talk about it on numberphile but then it
still not been checked so maybe we
shouldn't talk about it on numberphile
but then when all the blog started going
mad about it I thought so are my Oscars
I mean that's how you probe extra
dimensions you that's how you probe the
very small